[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ihr
könnt es schon sehen ungewohnte umgebung
nicht weiß ich sitze hier in meinem
alten zimmer und ich habe mir gestern
dieses wunderschöne led-licht besorgt
das ist wirklich ein gutes licht hat
keine ahnung
80 euro kostet oder so eigentlich wollte
ich nur so ein stab kaufen für 20 dann
ist es doch ein bisschen teurer geworden
weil ich habe so was noch nie gesehen
ich brauche es in erster linie für
meinem späteren zweikanal irgendwann
dann mal hintergrund vielleicht auch für
hauptkanal für hintergrund ich weiß noch
nicht dass gutes hier irgendwie also
darum geht es wird nicht um das gericht
aber ich zeige dass ich mal kurz
vielleicht stolz darauf kann man kann
die farbe ändern bahn war dann kann es
noch so ein wechsel machen also ist
schon nice und ich habe mich heute aber
bewusst für rot entschieden weil rot ist
auch die farbe von dem auto um das ist
heute geht's
[Musik]
jetzt sogar auf 197 1500 390 kilometer
ich versuche ist kurz und knapp zu
halten
der einzige grund warum ich dieses video
mache oder warum ich mich dazu
entschlossen habe das video zu machen
ist weil das video in dem ich praktisch
es geht um das günstigste auto der welt
also so wie es zumindest der video titel
dass ich damals schon für 50 euro
gekauft habt das war so ein alter bmw
e30 haben ja wahrscheinlich sehr viele
von euch gesehen und das video hat
mittlerweile fast 800.000 klicks und es
macht täglich auch noch mehrere weitere
1000 keine ahnung also das schauen
täglich noch zwei 3000 leute an und ich
kriege von dem tag an als das video
online gehen was ich auch verstehen kann
am anfang war das extrem ohne scheu
übertreibt jetzt nicht ich habe jeden
tag mindestens 50 mails bekommen wo
irgendwelche leute medien abkaufen
wollten was ich sogar auch verstehen
kann weil es das wirklich ein geiles
auto so an sich und es vorjahr noch auch
wenn das wirklich ja kann man das noch
paar nennen man kann es vielleicht ja
ist doch es kam auf jeden fall noch
voran und ich habe bestimmt schon 50 60
dieser anfragen beantwortet ich kann
auch nicht alle beantworten
aber wenn sich jemand so einen langen
text überlegt oder so einen text auch
schreibt mit den extra schickt dann
fühle ich mich auch schlecht wenn ich
darauf nicht antwortete hey so sieht es
gerade aus gerade leider noch nicht ich
möchte damit noch was machen und so
weiter viele von euch an das thema
wahrscheinlich auch schon wieder
vergessen viele aber auch nicht und dies
vergessen haben bei denen ist es jetzt
wieder vorhanden sag ich mal im
gedächtnis weil ich möchte dazu kurz was
sagen und vor allem da mal aufklären was
ich weiter vor hat das video ist jetzt
echt schon ein bisschen her und man kann
es vielleicht so sagen dass sich gerade
nicht wirklich über dieses auto verfüge
das kann sich aber wieder ändern auf
jeden fall das war dann halt einfach so
sachen wie ok wo stelle ich das jetzt
hin in köln so vor allem dass das war
ein bisschen schwierig und ich habe
nicht richtig nachgedacht so als ich das
video gemacht aber ich habe mir das
alles schon so vorgestellt wie ich das
mache aber ich bin halt auch kein auto
fachmann so ich kann mich zwar mit der
zeit so eigentlich mittlerweile ganz gut
mit autos aus aber ich bin kein
mechaniker und ich bin vielleicht ein
youtuber der einfach sich nur denken
wie kann ich jetzt das video möglichst
cool machen und vielleicht an euch auch
darauf heiß machen echte das auto wieder
auf das kriegt eine neue lackierung
neuen motor was auch immer ok motor ist
ein bisschen schwierig wobei was weiß
ich und ich habe gesehen damals dass
videos haben echt sehr gut an und ich
habe mich wirklich sehr bemüht dann
vielleicht eine lösung zu finden und
weitere parts mit dem auto drehen zu
können so und dann ging es los dann
dachte ich erst mal gut was braucht man
vielleicht mal eine neue lackierung das
soll von außen wieder schön aussehen
dann vielleicht neue reifen bisschen
vielleicht neue innenausstattung da gab
es ja genug ansatzpunkte die man auf
jeden fall hätte angehen können um das
auto wieder schöner und vor allem auch
besser zu machen problem war dann nur
das wird ganz schön teuer und damit
meine ich nicht 1000 2000 euro ich hätte
vielleicht vorher auch denken können
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich war
nicht bereit einfach mal für diese
videoreihe dann 15.000 euro hinzulegen
weil das auf mich klar ich verdiene
nicht schlecht keine frage aber das ist
auch für mich eine menge geld gewesen
und ich habe es versucht irgendwie
irgendwie vielleicht damals mit einer
kooperation mit irgendwem hinzukriegen
aber das war echt sehr sehr schwierig
und ich bin heute auch kein auto kanal
wo sich alles um autos dreht wie zum
beispiel bei dem delphi oder diese leute
davon grip da gibt es ja einige
beispiele
das sind erstens leute wie sich richtig
gut mit autos auskennen und zweitens die
auch ein unternehmen dahinter haben was
eine menge kohle landschaft was ich
halte das nicht hat und dann muss ich
halt irgendwann einsehen so dass es erst
mal nicht erst mal sehr schwierig wird
das projekt am leben zu halten und auch
weiter zu führen und ich habe mich
wieder auf meine anderen stelle
konzentriert ich hätte es wirklich
unfassbar gerne weitergeführt muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen
und jetzt ist aber folgendes geplant und
zwar habe ich jetzt doch jemanden
gefunden der sich vorstellen könnte das
eventuell mit mir zu machen das dauert
allerdings noch seine zwei drei vier
monate bis wir das dann angehen können
und das ist dann praktisch da kann man
vielleicht zu sagen der der sponsor von
dem projekt oder dass ich da jemanden
habt ja das ganze sponsert und da muss
ich aber auch sagen anders geht's nicht
also klar ich finde jetzt schon 10.000
euro nehmen und das auto geil machen so
aber das ja da müsst ihr verstehen dass
es halt auch eine menge geld ist so ich
hoffe einige von euch die wirklich auto
freaks sind da jetzt nicht böse
aber ich kann euch versprechen und ich
hoffe es selber das ist schnellstmöglich
damit weitergeht und ich habe mir das
wirklich für 2020 anfang 2020 fest
eingeplant dass ich mit diesem auto noch
was machen möchte und das ist jetzt
immer noch nicht geklärt tut mir echt
leid aber am anfang habe ich mir halt
irgendwie einfach viel zu leicht
vorgestellt
die geile sache mitzumachen deswegen
hoffe ich dass hier noch ein bisschen
geduld habt euch trotzdem vielleicht auf
die videos schon mal freut und ich mag
solche projekte hat auch das ist mal was
anderes für mich was aufwendigeres als
meine anderen sachen die ich sonst mache
und da ist man dann wirklich so richtig
drin und man kann natürlich auch mehrere
partnern also ich habe da wirklich
richtig bock drauf und ich hoffe das
kommt schnellstmöglich zu stande
deswegen hat alle die mich seitdem immer
wieder gefragt haben was dann mit dem
auto ist auch so dass abkaufen können
für 2 300 400 euro ich habe angebote
bekommen für das auto über 3000 euro von
irgendwelchen liebhabern oder so dass er
wirklich krass aber ich warte erstmal
auf jeden fall noch ab dann hoffen wir
natürlich dass ich das möglichst cool
umsetzen kann
ja das war's aber nicht den kanal
wir sehen uns dann sonntag wieder dann
gibt es wieder ein normales video holen
heute hatten wir mal halt so ein kleines
lava video und auch wenn viele von euch
immer sagen youtuber haben doch so viel
geld so also für mich ist kommt so ein
projekt hallo in frage wenn wenn man da
irgend ein sponsor findet oder so wenn
ich jetzt vielleicht noch mal eine
doppelte reichweite oder so hätte dann
wäre es vielleicht mal möglich zu sagen
okay ich blätter jetzt mal für drei
videos dass die menge an geld hin die
dafür benötigt wird und habe dann drei
richtig geile videos macht zwar
insgesamt verlust aber es ist trotzdem
geil geil der content für den für den
kanal so aber das ist leider für mich
war es einfach zu viel geld ich hoffe
ihr versteht das wird es auch nicht zu
viel hier noch abschweifen
das war's australien instagram alex w